I I'm sorry I just need to stress this  before we wrap up this you know segment  I want you all to realize where we are  as a nation  we're at a point where one of the oldest  and most prominent political parties had  decided to run someone with a severe  mental disability restricting their  ability to comprehend words that are  said before them  we can make a little bit more crass we  are at the point where the Democrats are  running  and have run and won with brain damaged  candidates I'm not saying that to dig at  fetterman I'm not using brain damage as  a kind of insult it is a fact Joe Biden  I believe had an aneurysm and he got  metal plates put in his brain he  struggles to speak fetterman recently  within the past what was it five months  ago had a stroke I feel bad I do not  wish that on anybody  you gotta know when to bow out but here  we are in America  this is the point where this nation is